[Applause]
all right so the house voted last night
to censure Squad member congresswoman to
leave over her repeated anti-semitic
remarks most notably her endorsement of
the chant from The River To The Sea now
if you're not familiar with it I will
tell you what it means it means that is
the call for the destruction of the
entire state of Israel 22 Democrats
voted to censure congresswoman to leave
but her allies in the squad they're not
happy about it let's take a look Mr
Speaker I rise in opposition to this
censure resolution that is blatantly
islamophobic anti-democratic and an
utter waste of time this resolution is
as dishonest as it is unproductive what
is true here is that every single one of
them has not acknowledge the fact that
Palestinians are dying in the tens of
thousands but will continue to say it is
us who are not acknowledging Humanity
this is the place where our black and
brown staff members repeatedly speak of
experiencing racism and sexism
islamophobia get pushed off of elevators
xenophobia and more right here in this
workplace and here with reaction human
rights attorney founder of the lawfare
project Brooke Goldstein is back with us
um Brooke great to see
you you know I I really it really takes
my breath away you know that this
weekend we saw at our own White House
chanting of Allahu abbar it really
scares me that in London they've had
massive protests over hundreds of
thousands of people we've had we've
heard anti-semitic comments in the halls
of Congress Times Square New York in
college universities all around this
country in Australia they actually were
chanting gas the Jews F the Jews I never
thought I'd see this Brooke in my
lifetime what's
happening me neither Sean I'm incredibly
concerned about what I see as a a major
national security threat to this country
and it's certainly not
islamophobia the very real threat that
we are facing in the United States of
America is pramas members of Congress
pramas
indoctrination on our campuses funded by
States like Qatar and pramas rallies
that are turning violent on our streets
now we can debate the level of
anti-muslim hate or anti Jewish hate but
what I will not do is legitimize the
islamophobia Clarion call by America's
number one bigot and that is Rashida
Talib who herself has called for the
genocide of the Jewish people who
supports an illegal and racist boycott
against Jewish persons and companies and
who spreads blood lials at pramas
rallies and I ask you one thing Sean
because she came out against a bill that
was proposed to revoke the Visas of
Palestinians in the United States and we
can debate the merits of that bill but
if revoking the Visas if removing the
Visas of Palestinians from the United
States is racist what then is calling
for the removal of the Jewish people
from the river to the sea is that
justifiable racism or is that just the
height of hypocrisy that is virulent
hatred anti-Semitism there's a gentleman
in our audience tonight and maybe we can
get a camera on him he lost a dear
friend that was at the concert uh that
day October 7th and he gave me this hat
before the show and you know this is
what Israel's living through um Brooke
always great to see you and our prayers
are with the people of Israel as they
fight back against terrorism and evil in
our time hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else